languages change over time but how fast
let's say you fall into a coma hearing
your language spoken all around you you
snap awake in the same place but at a
different time they're still speaking
your language but you can't understand a
word how long were you out how long can
a language last before it becomes
unrecognizable
[Music]
last time we met an eccentric Australian
tongue called gerbil a language where
nouns can be edible or harmful where you
have to talk completely differently
around your in-laws and we're speaking
vaguely is considered a serious flaw and
they don't even have a word for language
at least it used to be that way because
when linguist came back to visit the
gerbil nine decades later their language
had changed then we heard from Swadesh
who argued that actually no all
languages change at the same pace
replacing core vocabulary at a constant
rate keeping over 80% of their most
basic words after a thousand years
Swadesh then used his vocabulary lists
and calculations to draw a line marking
how long we'd expect to wait before
dialects of a single language evolved
into separate tongues a line in the sand
the elusive moment of change itself spot
any problems with this idea these
researchers shorted they grab their
Swadesh lists and pointed them at two
sibling languages Norwegian and
Icelandic the basic question they wanted
Swadesh to answer was this how many
years had passed between Old Norse and
Norwegian and how many between Old Norse
and Icelandic looking at word list for
replacement plugging that stable rate
assumption it looks like Norwegian
diverged a thousand years ago not a bad
estimate actually while modern Icelandic
is 200 something years old in other
words no one should be speaking
Icelandic right now call up Iceland your
language is a mistake the numbers don't
lie
today thanks to debunking x' like this
and the fact that Icelandic exists
historical linguists accept that the
rate of language change varies and for
various reasons
according to this paper one factor could
be population size in a computer
simulation smaller populations borrowed
and replaced words faster than bigger
communities the author of that gerbil
grammar Dickson himself proposed another
factor
he called SWAT Ash's idea the chimera of
glottal chronology and argued instead
that languages have long stable periods
but then change and punctuated bursts
during moments of social upheaval so is
that why gerbil changed so much so fast
a small population and a quick
punctuation well a careful look at the
switch from traditional gerbil to young
durable suggests another variable the
biggest reason why the language changed
so much in just decades language death a
few decades before Dixon's grammar about
30 gerbil none still lived around the
Upper Tully River hanging on to the old
ways but these days it seems like nobody
is learning gerbil threatening even
young gerbil with extinction it's not
just assimilating to Australian English
or turning into a bare-bones pidgin or
Creole this researcher tells us it's not
that simple
behind the steep change from traditional
gerbil to young durable was the smooth
oldest to youngest drop-off gerbil has
been dying its own death and language
death is its own variable with all these
complexities how long do we have to be
out before we wake up to a brand new
language
it depends some tongues seem to keep
their shape over a thousand years others
do indeed change quickly within
centuries but take another look at that
question we started with how long can a
language last before it becomes
unrecognizable not unintelligible to
earlier speakers utterly unrecognizable
see even if a time-traveling gerbil
speaker couldn't understand the language
they might still be able to pick out
familiar words how do we know this will
happen because it has happened this
isn't the first time gerbil has evolved
we got a glimpse of its past changes in
part one when we met a relative a gerbil
where the word for dog is
dog that word took linguistic know how
to prove it was actually related to
gerbil not English but other patterns
among Australia's languages are easier
to recognize of whatever you think about
Swadesh lists here's a fun use for them
compare basic vocabulary from a bunch of
Australian languages and look for
cognates comparing cognates and sound
changes in grammar linguists focusing on
australia's languages looked far back
beyond gerbil to recover its entire
family the pom on human languages there
is dissent Dixon in particular came to
reject this grouping but the consensus
is that Palma Neumann constitutes the
largest family on the continent by far
using various lines of evidence hominin
is held to be around 4,000 to 5,000
years old which is intriguing because
look what happens when we estimate the
ages of other language families we get
similar time depths the one aberration
here seems to be proto afro-asiatic a
story for another time some historical
linguists warned that they don't do
dates but some that do see a limit here
comparing languages can only take us
several thousand years into the past of
course in my Tower of Babel first
language video we did meet some
Mavericks who dare to go even further so
how long should we keep that
hypothetical linguistics patient under
to make sure they wake up to a change to
language well within hundreds of years
we could expect degraded intelligibility
with hand-waving on dates and exactly
how understandable it will be but within
many thousands of years even distant
traces of the language may have
dissolved they'll keep your apologies
handy in case this answer is too vague
for the jerubbaal now stick around and
subscribe for language
[Music]